as a millennial or as the oldest
Millennial every generation when you're
the youngest generation that's kind of
coming up every generation gets a bad
rap right every generation feels the
heat from the older generation right so
before gender Z everyone was talking
[ __ ] about Millennials they're lazy
their entitled ain't doing nothing but
now the oldest Millennials are turning
40 or 41 now so it's like all right
they're not kids anymore right so even
before that Gen X they were all Slackers
Dazed and Confused days those movies
Baby Boomers who are basically our
parents and Beyond or grandparents for
some of you guys out there they were the
hippies Woodstock that was that kind of
generation so everyone wants to kind of
put labels on different Generations now
you guys are kind of the ones getting
[ __ ] on these days by media gen Z
what have you but the reality is you
guys are the future of America today you
guys are the future of society so what
are the sub just real quick what are
some of the stereotypes that you've seen
thrown your way being you know young 20s
what have you seen I mean gen Z men
these days The Stereotype is that they
have no ambition they have no drive or
they want to do something but they don't
go out and get it I feel like that is a
reality too I feel like so many people
see this quick success online they might
see my story and be like oh this guy he
made it I could go ahead and do it too
but they don't actually put in the
effort to do it it's like people that
are in this generation are now more
looking for like microwave success like
they think that because they see
somebody making in 30 days they're gonna
go out and do the same thing they don't
necessarily have that same patience that
it requires to actually build something
great and I didn't really have that like
ingrained in me I just followed the
process and I've then understood that it
takes time to build things so you know I
learned it through that way but that
would be I see the main thing with men
that I see in my age bracket they want
to get rich quick they want to have
success quick the microwave generation I
told you the story about my buddy
Marcelo and Fernandez who made it to SNL
when I met him he was 19 trying to do
stand-up at clubs paid his dues work
here valuetainment only in day did it
next thing you know always 25 years old
he's on SNL yeah but you don't you
weren't there six seven years ago when
he was 18 19 trying to do stand up in
the club but that's a kid who recognized
very early yo I'm in it for the long
haul I love this whenever long it takes
I'm in it I don't think a lot of young
people fully appreciate how long it
takes to really reach success people
want immediate gratification right well
like as a result I think people are much
more depressed because of it because
they feel like they should have
something quicker and they don't
appreciate that it takes time to build
something great and what you realize
when you do start to see things come
together in your life is that that
Journey that long haul to build
something is the best part even when you
make your first million first 10 million
you are so appreciative of those days
that she was sleeping on the bunk bed
just trying to get it out of the mud
like those are the days that you respect
the most so like to people out there you
have to understand that it's a marathon
and I know that's cliche but it's true
like Adam you know you've been in the
game for a while and now you're doing
interviews with the top guys like you
started out a long time ago and now
you're getting it going bro let me tell
you how true that is Jordan how much I
appreciate that because not only do I do
interviews now people are starting to
interview me right so even I went on
Fresh pit they interviewed me and
imagine if my So Adam how'd you make
your money yeah bro I just bought crypto
now millionaire what's up like that's my
story but the reality was I was sleeping
on Friends couches I was a party boy in
South Beach I had no direction I had to
move out of Miami into Boca I started
cold calling for two years before I made
money I'm dealing with struggles I'm
dealing with drama can't keep a girl
because I'm broke as [ __ ] sleeping on
couches finally I make money like the
whole come up story is the whole premise
of why you can appreciate having monies
because I [ __ ] came from nothing and
look at me now but if you don't have
that story and if it's just a microwave
story it's like Yeah I wanted money and
I got it look at me now it's like that
nobody wants to hear that story yeah
it's such a far-fetched idea and it's
what makes a great life you know you
watch these movies or these stories like
the movie would be no fun if the guy
just started and he got got it and then
credits roll you know 100 The Pursuit of
Happiness Will Smith yeah Rocky you know
like these stories are true Testaments
to what it takes to find success love
happiness and life it is a journey that
we're all four of us still on today so
so back to my initial point that is
um sort of the knock on gen Z but it's
also somewhat reality yeah it's just I
think to tie it all back together is
that our current generation I think has
a harder time understanding that than
ever because they see so many success
stories right in front of their faces
all day long on YouTube Instagram and
Tick Tock and as a result it makes them
feel like I'm doing something wrong or I
am not capable of doing this when you
are you just have to put one foot
forward and keep going every day from
your perspective Mia what kind of
stereotypes do you see from uh regarding
young women elaborating more on what you
said um I definitely do agree as far as
we are the generation that believes in
instant success kind of like a cup
noodle you know
um but what people don't realize is it
is 10 years of hard work to have that
overnight success like for example me
um a lot of people like when they when I
just tell my story and I just tell it
very quick I'm just like one day I just
made a video and it got 25 million views
and my life was different but if we
really elaborate on that and really
analyze what I did I've been making
these videos since I was 12 getting
comfortable in front of you know acting
in front of a camera alone in my room
editing all of that stuff honing like
perfecting the way that I deliver jokes
um
comedic timing all of that stuff uh so
at the end of the day it we're used to
instant gratification especially with
Tick Tock and YouTube we get information
so quickly we don't have to work for it
uh we can just we can become politicians
with just tweeting something because we
we we're also the generation of social
social social
justice Warriors pardon me
um so but I do think that there's a good
and bad to that um I do feel like my
generation is a little bit more
sensitive but it's also wow what a
privilege that now we can voice these
concerns that we have and ultimately
make a movement I think that the ball
really is in generation Z's court and
how to
focus on controlling your emotions
thinking more logically and using the
tools that we have been given as far as
communication
to really make an impact that is going
to benefit the generations after us yeah
everybody's on communication yeah
correct and that could be a good or bad
thing but I think it could be net
positive If people could listen to me or
what she's saying here yeah you guys
ever had a beeper no no my first my
first one though I had like this and a
little keyboard
listen guys I remember when beepers came
on the scene we're like what
you got a beeper dog oh yeah if
someone's getting touching me they just
they could send me a beep yeah and the
beep and and like you would have codes
like one four three was I love you like
187 was like I'm gonna kill you but that
was a I remember like in 10th Grade yo
people are getting beepers what you sure
are you a millennium
we know what we were talking about
probably about them
um
correct technically the zenio is what
they call it Gen X and and Millennials
where they uh the cusp 1980. I would go
back to that for a little while though
like you know the iPhone sometimes man I
just I'm grateful for it and the
opportunities that it has but man
sometimes I just want to throw this
thing away and just like take a break
for a long time everything's got
positives and negatives everything just
too many people have an opinion now yeah
yeah it's like not backed well back in
the day back in the day
you didn't know what your friend from
ninth grades
philosophy on politics were because
there was no outlet for them there was
no Facebook there was no YouTube there
was no social media no Instagram it's
like yeah cool like see ya see on the
Block maybe I don't know but now you
know what like Aunt Brenda's philosophy
is because she's tweeting and
instagramming all day not even just your
aunt random people on the internet that
you've never met before and that even
skews their perspective if you let it so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire saucecast click right here
foreign
[Music]